pants you can harbor has a singular
focus the human face
in recent years Ahava has taken more
than 300 portrait photos all over the
world
his theme is humankind in the 21st
century he tries to capture images that
convey a personality and get under your
skin you can get Emmanuel mine and I can
only convey my own impressions I want to
show the globalized world I live in well
that's not just something I show by
traveling to distant places when I go to
the Brandenburg Gate in Berlin that's
already global either so what I try to
convey is an awareness of how we are all
living in a global world as Gannett has
40 investor 990 faces is a long-term
project that will span years in the end
it will include 30 portraits from 33
different locations the result will be a
global portrait of humanity he's already
taken pictures at Berlin's Brandenburg
Gate in Papua New Guinea and the Eiffel
Tower in Paris
there will be one book of photography
for each site Java began the project
four years ago and has already published
ten books mark off topic
I like the tactile and physical
dimension of things I want to be able to
smell feel experience the places I mean
that's how I get to the essence of what
I'm working on yeah the Matta q9 Compton
in addition to his published volumes
GABA is now showing his work in colognes
photo book museums
it's an excursion through the world of
photography books with 30 different
exhibitions in all the museum is housed
in a former industrial hall colognes
cosmic Factory the world's first
transatlantic telephone cable was
produced here in the early 20th century
the museum's founder Marcus chadon says
the museum also aims to link the entire
world is the starting point but our
museum wants to thrill viewers by
creating a global visual literature
photography books can be read by anyone
in Indonesia in Japan Brazil everyone
understands it
haba is fascinated by places where
cultures encounter one another in
Cologne he's setting out to explore a
multicultural district he always works
in the same way
first he explores the location then he
tracks down images that convey a sense
of place and he looks for the small
revealing details once he has a feel for
the location he begins his actual work I
usually don't ask permission that's how
I get a natural-looking shot there -
Makani but people often notice what I'm
doing then I explain my project if they
hate the picture and ask me to get rid
of it I do that often they say what a
great picture and feelers I'm oh gentle
his photo
none of the portraits are staged Java
doesn't use a flash and he doesn't
process his images digitally he wants to
capture the moment in natural light
Bava exhibited the first stage of his
project in Istanbul this year's
exhibition includes 330 photos and it's
the first time he's shown them in
Germany his concept doesn't become
visible in a single shot it's the entire
series and diversity of the faces that
make up the work the faces are so
striking they're not just beautiful
faces they're expressive faces that
capture an essence they don't look
retouched or photoshopped that's
something you rarely see these days in
the age of digital snapshots the photo
book Museum in Cologne aims to show a
different dimension and to establish the
photography book as an art form in its
own right
Albertus portable heli photography books
are undergoing a process of
democratization in our digital world and
they need to have a forum to bring this
digitization to life so the photo museum
can be an example for countries across
the world
colognes photo book museum is charting
this new path with the work of
hans-juergen harbor